[Applause]
a few years ago entrepreneur jim clark
envisioned a boat built purely for speed
a boat so light
so fast
that it would shatter every record it
attempted
in 2014
that dream became a reality with
100-foot monohull comanche it's by
almost any measure the fastest monohull
in the world
with her revolutionary design she has
since been dominating the world of
professional sailing blowing competitors
out of the water
now skipper ken reed is on a mission to
break one of sailing's most prestigious
benchmarks the transatlantic record
it's one of the holy grails of
ocean-going records a grueling journey
of
2880 nautical miles from new york to the
southern tip of england
the crew's success depends largely on
how elite navigator stan honey can
predict harness and adapt to the
atlantic's fickle weather patterns
if broken this record will secure
comanche's place among the most
successful racing boats in sailing
history
overview of comanche is really simple
it's uh jim and christy clark's dream to
have the ultimate race boat the ultimate
monohull race boat clark's team analyzed
every aspect of the modern monohull then
set out to build the next iteration of
racing boats principally designed to
break open ocean records
the build team that we assembled are the
best of the best there was no expense
spent in creating this thing it's either
carbon or titanium with the engineering
structure with the use of carbon fiber
with this canting keel mechanism this
boat is literally half the weight of a
boat like this even 10 15 years ago ken
reed the skipper and jim clark the owner
gave the designer a very very clear
mission which was to design and build
the fastest possible boat it was legal
to enter into the major ocean races
around the world and to ideally set the
course records for these events
that sort of clarity of objective was i
think critical to the boat coming out
the way it did you know it's meant to
make a statement in the sailing world
and
and you can just tell by its outward
appearance
it makes a statement
the level of detail that they take in in
building these boats then filters down
throughout the whole sailing team
ken is among the best sailors in the
world he's
a commentator for the americas cup he's
extremely knowledgeable you know about
sailing and he's a great skipper
ultimately
what i'm pretty good at doing is getting
a compatible group of all-stars from all
around the globe that can actually
handle a boat like this it's like a
formula one car you let it get away from
you it'll get away from you
[Music]
it is a very dangerous boat everybody
who's on board this boat either has
america's cup volvo ocean race grand
prix high-end racing background it's
their career it's their job my job
specifically is really quite easy i get
the sale of the coolest boat in the
world i guess as the skipper of the boat
i'm ultimately responsible for
the safety of the crew the big decisions
you know i work very closely with stan
honey the navigator on where we position
ourselves in the ocean it's critical
because the navigator and the skipper
work together very closely and then
where we overlap and work together is in
the tactic area
[Music]
the boat's a 100 foot screaming machine
that has been built to break every
record in the world that we can and
she's on her way to doing that
once in the water
comanche went straight for her
competitors
[Music]
wild oats is the boat to knock off and
we're here for a reason but there's also
three or four other really good boats in
this event that could do the same exact
thing so we just got to go out and sail
well and let the chips fall
the sheer size of it it looks different
to any other boat out there at the
moment
i think it's fair to say we got the
fastest hundred footer in the world you
saw what it did off the starting line or
what it did down that first run and we
were 30 miles ahead when we broke we
love this boat
we've had good luck racing in those
races and setting the records this
boat's unique because it's the fastest
in the world
with wind in their sails the comanche
team set their sights on sailing's most
prestigious prize the transatlantic
record
[Music]
stan honey is a legend in our sport when
you think of all the great navigators
stan is one of those guys right at the
top of the list who comes to mind the
amount of work that he puts into it to
make these attempts happen without him
it wouldn't happen so the transatlantic
monohull record is
probably the most prestigious sailing
record of annie in 1905 the
transatlantic record was first set by
the schooner atlantic
it took her 12 days and four hours to
cross a benchmark that stood for 100
years
since then
only four boats have improved on her
record
the current project we're setting out to
do is to try to set the monohull record
for the fastest transatlantic passage
that record is currently set at 6 days
seventeen hours by marisha
marashad did as well as any boat could
do
in that tactic where you're gonna have
to use two systems to get across the
ocean
so what we were trying to do was to take
an entirely different approach which
nobody had ever done before in a
monohull but take a single system all
the way across you know he he watches
the weather just religiously looking for
all these small little things that might
happen
i had access to 11 years of historical
weather data so i routed comanche every
six hours for each of the last 11 years
from june through november and what i
discovered was that there was only two
possibilities per year on average where
comanche could
stay ahead of a southwesterly storm the
whole way across you can't take the
ocean for granted this is man against
ocean this is men against the elements
if i've learned anything you start to
just get a little cocky in the ocean and
it'll bite you hard
july 2016
stan honey spots a moving low in the
westerlies
potentially favorable for an atlantic
crossing
within a day the international comanche
team is assembled in new york city
waiting for a green light
it was kind of a cruel turn of fate that
it turned out that the perfect weather
had evolved in a time when kenny
couldn't join us volcanic just came at a
period where he had a prior commitment
with the americas cup but that's the
nature of weather
if comanche launches captain casey smith
will take the helm as skipper oh my
pants to start with
[Laughter]
but at that point kenny knew
just how hard it is to find these
opportunities and said okay well i can't
make it but you guys got to go to be
able to
be told that hey you're going to be the
guy in charge and i was really really
happy to be in that position and trusted
like that casey is an enormously
experienced sailor and he was the boat
captain so he's the guy in charge of
moving the boat around between events so
nobody knows the boat better than casey
uh casey in the pit nick dana at the rig
the transatlantic was a very interesting
one for us because uh we had three false
starts
you're waiting for that exact window and
you have to be ready at any moment so
your life's pretty much on hold
at this point we're not that confident
that this was actually the one
we are getting constant information from
stan we want to start
as close as we can to the front
but ahead of the thunderstorms because
if the thunderstorms catch us you guys
know what happened
it felt like
a bit like launch day for nasa where um
you're waiting for that
exact window and you have to be ready at
any moment this is the
put yourself in harm's way to try to do
something that nobody else has ever done
before
[Music]
and then when we pushed off the dock and
started motoring out that's when it
really was like wow
we're doing it we're gonna go
amazing
[Music]
it's real it's happening
we positioned ourselves about a mile
away from the ambrose light which gives
us enough runway to hit the start line
at full speed
we had the sail combination that we
wanted to use we had the perfect wind it
was time to let it rip
the acceleration doing 25 knots to 30
knots
doing that jump in such a short amount
of time can often put you on your butt
16 58 16. and we can't pass the ambrose
light fully lit up
everyone gave a huge hoot and holler as
we went past the start line and off we
went
[Music]
and it's pretty radical you've got all
the sail area up you've got all the
power in the world you need so you know
for a start you don't want to mess it up
england is there 3 100 miles now
we're gonna knock this bastard off
[Music]
but just as they're off things take a
dangerous turn as comanche tangles with
a formidable thunderstorm the worst part
of it the most dangerous part
weather-wise was actually the first
night and that next morning
we started ahead of a front and the
thunderstorms proceeding the front came
out earlier than expected and kind of
gobbled us up which was unexpected and
you know we definitely
had to change our plan adapt on the go
sail a course that we weren't expecting
to sail and the first thing in my mind
is is it over are we are we done are we
sailing home and going on standby again
for hours the team battles through the
wind and waves of the unforeseen
lightning squall
you know you can't control the lightning
the lightning does what it wants to do
and so you basically just put that out
of your mind and focus on the sailing
you focus on what you can control
i thought it was over when the
thunderstorms came i thought it was
actually over but luckily we were able
to find a little narrow bit of breeze up
up close to land and
and escape
and we managed to just wiggle our way
out of it and uh and keep on going
[Music]
well tough morning day two um the
thunderstorms which were uh rudolph over
the sort of central america came out and
got us now we've popped out the other
side and we're back in the forecast wind
so uh looking good heading east at pace
it's probably closer to a dive
expedition we we spend a lot of time
underwater all of our gear is our only
line of defense from
becoming totally saturated turning into
a giant raisin you've got 18 guys on
board and it's for five and a half days
so it's pretty tight quarters even
though it is a hundred foot boat you're
sharing bunks sharing bowls you're
sharing water bottles for drinking and
everything for the two groups of eight
we do a four hour on four hour system
this race we just did a simple four on
four off you know traditional watch
system
that's a challenge in itself you know
waking up every four hours to come on
deck and do your watch
and then off you go again you might
sleep for three hours out of that when
you're down when you've eaten
if you're lucky you get your four hours
off watch but you never miss your four
hours on deck and when you're off watch
you got to do everything else it's when
you've got to do the cooking do the
tidying up do the eating
and try to get some sleep the four hours
goes by pretty darn quick
so you have your helmsman who are
they'll drive the boat for two hours
you've got your trimmers of the sails
who are basically the engine making the
boat go fast so i'm one of the uh the
bright individuals that is on the front
of the boat that's basically taking on a
lot of the dangerous situations up front
we deal with all the sails going up and
down and then you've got a lot of the
guys who are required for the mussels
and everything to pull those sails in
the more prestigious of the records are
set by boats where all of the sail
handling
is done with human power we have six
brining pedestals so we have to pull any
sails up or trim them in we have 12 guys
just going at it until you know the trim
is happy or you know the sales up
you're working the sales you're grinding
you're steering you're always sort of
losing losing losing losing against the
sleep
there's no place i'd rather be even
though
it's a terrible place in a lot of
respects
i wish i had new boots
being on board comanche in the middle of
the atlantic ocean is something that
you realise how small you are out there
you realise that you're you're a speck
personally i love the silence
you know when you're flying your
aeroplane across and you look down
you're never going to see us it's huge
you know if we were to lose all
communications and everything you have a
hard time finding us
another thing that you tend to notice
early on is how big the ocean is you
know if you're sailing around the world
you can just sail for day after day
after day after day even on a really
fast boat
you have a lot of time to think when
you're out there
the day slows down a lot
you're living every hour
it's kind of cool to disconnect and
you're out there in the elements
the wind and the waves
it's nothing like it's it's
it's crazy
you have a lot of time to reflect on on
everything in your life but as well you
you have a lot of time to appreciate
where you are in the world all of us
were
definitely captivated by the sea at that
point it's amazing
you get the clouds getting lower and
lower and lower and the sky turns more
and more gray and then you get this sort
of drizzle
as it starts to rain and that's what we
had all the way across the ocean just
kind of this gray
drizzle
things move differently compared to
other keel boats i've sailed on one
minute you're doing
10 miles now and then you blink and
honestly you're up to 20 to 30 miles an
hour the thing's a weapon it just goes
forever and it's not a it's not a really
short awesome the things being awesome
for
days on end
okay guys there's ice contours we're
keeping track of day three comanche
faces its greatest obstacle navigating
through an area known to have icebergs
you've got to watch what's going on out
here though there's a bit of fog around
there was a very small patch of
southwesterly that we had to stay in and
that patch of wind took us right through
an area where there was known to be ice
you couldn't see more than
a hundred feet in front of the boat
fully engulfed in fog you know doing 20
knots a hundred feet isn't enough
morning to avoid the ice
and it sounds crazy to have guys on deck
keeping a careful watch for icebergs
when you can't even see the the bow but
a funny thing happens when you get close
to an iceberg
the icebergs are just unbelievably white
that they appear to glow
you know you're sailing along in pea
suit fog suddenly gets a little bit
clearer and then a part of the horizon
looks funny because it looks like it's
glowing the consequence of hitting
icebergs is so severe and it's like you
just turn it out of your mind you're
like we just can't you prepare for it
but
if it happens it happens
on the lured side of an iceberg you can
get these small bits of ice called
growlers they're too small to see on
radar you know they're like the size of
a pickup truck if it hit the boat
exactly wrong it's potential that it
could punch a big enough hole into the
boat so that the boat could sink
to be fair it's hard to sleep when
you're off watch and go down below
because you know the other watch is
going through exactly the same thing so
it's a little bit nervous
not my not my favorite part of sailing i
don't like it yeah
and that's why when we sleep down below
we sleep with our
our feet forward so
if you stop suddenly your feet will take
the impact not your head
guys we're out of the area that they're
known to be icebergs and we've got 20
more minutes until we're out of the area
where there's any possibility of an
iceberg
yeah right now by the uh
gps for
22 miles a little over an hour to go
[Music]
we knew we were on the pace we knew that
the time was right
and a lot of transatlantic records fail
right at the finish boats get within a
hundred mile of the finish and then they
stop do the light air
and i knew once we were two-thirds of
the way across that that wasn't going to
happen that that low was powerful enough
to push that ridge and we were going to
have good breeze all the way in
[Music]
what are you looking for
land yeah we're looking for the lizard
should be on the bow about 10 miles you
can't quite see it yet
and the finish is off the lizard
lighthouse in southwest england
[Music]
essentially we had crushed the record
the goal was to improve marysha's record
by a day we were able to improve it by
one day three hours
we pioneered a completely new tactic
which is the tactic of
doing it in a single system and it was
just barely possible to do that with a
boat like comanche and i don't think it
would have been possible with a monohull
it was any slower this boat was built to
do that it did it we're all very happy
it's such a special thing to be able to
break this transatlantic record huge
thanks to the weather guides to allow us
to do it as well because that's what it
really took i'm happy i'm tired
i think for everyone in the crew it was
a
something they're real proud of because
these records live forever
a record like the transatlantic record
is one of the most prestigious events in
all of sailing even if somebody beats
our record it'll always show that
comanche took you know one day three
hours off the previous one
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
you